the state department is saying it has
information that russia will increase
its attacks on ukraine in the week ahead
tensions are growing even higher because
of a deadly car bombing outside moscow
that killed a russian tv commentator the
putin government is blaming ukraine and
claiming this video on your screen now
shows the attacker crossing the border
ukraine meanwhile is denying any
involvement saying it wouldn't make any
sense for them deborah powder is in
ukraine's capital for us tracking
reaction to the bombing
a memorial service in moscow for daria
dugina killed instantly when her car
blew up on the outskirts of the capital
the kremlin has blamed ukraine for the
hit claiming to have solved the case
within 24 hours and releasing video of a
suspect they call a ukrainian agent but
kiev has vigorously denied any
involvement dugine's father alexander
dugan is a vocal supporter of the war
now the violence against ukraine he has
long campaigned for has entered his own
life
dubbed putin's brain it's believed he
was the intended target it's unclear
what the motive is but former kremlin
politician elia panamarov who was forced
into exile after voting against the
annexation of crimea claims it's the
work of an underground russian
resistance group that he's been in
direct contact with and what is the
ultimate goal
the ultimate goal is to overthrow and to
stop the war and to build
the the government
of social justice he said as many as 10
000 people could be involved in this
resistance
do you think we will see more of this
kind of thing obviously
obviously it's just the beginning
ukraine however is bracing itself for
revenge attacks the country was already
on edge ahead of tomorrow's independence
day which coincides with the six month
anniversary of russia's invasion
regardless of who masterminded the bomb
there are fears that russia will use it
as an excuse to ramp up strikes this
week for cbs morning's debra patter
keith